notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean françois copé bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes le
maire les républicains de mots on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes ou un
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour stéphane
bern est bonjour au riad stéphane qui
dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france
on commence par les régionales et jean
castex qui défendra donc cet après midi
au parlement le maintien des élections
locales au mois de juin puisque les
maires ont voté en ce sens est ce que
c'est la bonne décision pour vous afin
c'est pour moi c'est la bonne décision
pour une raison simple c'est que nous
avons maintenant suffisamment de recul
pour organiser les élections aient
suffisamment de temps pour le faire
et puis personne ne pourrait comprendre
alors que les tous les autres pays
européens ont organisé y compris dans
ces périodes de crise sanitaire des
élections que la france ne le fasse pas
les pays-bas l'allemagne pour ne citer
que ces deux exemples portugal outre
atlantique les états unis donc en
réalité
ce qui moi m'a paru très très troublant
c'est que le président de la république
qui se veut nouveau monde
il utilisait finalement un peu une
vieille fille ciel vient vieille vieille
parce que même les autres partis avant
n'avait pas osé faire ça quand même
alors que l'on sait qu effectivement en
marche est en très grande difficulté sur
le scrutin régional il faut dans ces
cas-là l'accepter et accepter de jeu
démocratique pour vous il voulait
reporter pour des raisons politiques
énoncées
écoutez franchement je crois que
personne n'était dupe a et donc c'est
bien que ça se termine comme ça j'ai pas
adorer le petit coup qui a consisté dans
48 heures a organisé un vote des maires
dans des conditions qui étaient quand
même pas très très très très orthodoxe
mais finalement ça a donné ce score est
donc ça clôt le débat
il ya pourtant une participation
exceptionnelle ces mères 69% des des
mers plus de 24000 d'entre elles ont
participé à cette consultation express
effectivement ça c'est pas un score qui
vous fait rêver en terme de
participation
si bien sûr mais on aura on aura le même
aux régionales c'est
je ne sais pas obsédé malheureusement la
participation à une baisse beaucoup
depuis ces dernières années mais mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que une mobilisation
des maires à paris ce qui n'est pas
comparable
c'est un sondage qui a été fait par sms
dans des conditions n'étaient pas du
tout rigoureuse mais qui a été fait à la
demande du gouvernement et finalement
gouvernement espérait avec les maires
disent non et ils ont dit oui vous avez
répondu vous oui bien sûr bien sûr et je
dors ses arguments sur cère jacob et
hier il disait c'est l'arroseur arrosé
finalement oui dans ces cas là on a tous
notre petit punchline am enfin pourquoi
je ne voulais pas 10 parce que je me
doutais que d'autres l'avaient fait
avant moi
juste un mot sur les dates puisque
richard ferrand dit ce matin que jean
castex pourrait proposer de les décaler
d'une semaine six séries abc pouvait
juste arrêter de tout changer tout les
toutes les 10 minutes pour convenance
personnelle
on va laisser le premier ministe donner
les dates et si elles correspondent
grosso modo ce que nous souhaitons c'est
un décalage d'une semaine tout ira bien
voilà est-ce que ça va pas quand même si
ça permet de sauver la face de monsieur
ferrand 1
est-ce que ça va quand ça va pas quand
même être un scrutin difficile organisé
il ya quand même sept cent mille
assesseurs à trouver parmi les rares
élus qui étaient opposés qui sont
opposés à la tenue de ces élections en
juin il y avait cet argument qui
revenait en dire est ce qu'on va réussir
à trouver le monde en quantité
suffisante pour tenir les seydoux et
ruraux ont à la fois pour les
départementales et régionales
d'abord il faut se projeter et c'est à
la fin juin
d'ici là beaucoup de choses on se passer
on a le temps d'organiser nous allons
faire les choses comme il faut savez on
en a vu d'autres depuis un an nous les
maires 1
quand il nous a fallu en catastrophe que
créer ex nihilo des centres de dépistage
trouver des masques parce que si on
avait vu juste attendu l'état n'aurait
rien eu ensuite les vaccinations qu'on a
organisées dans toutes nos villes
j'espère qu'un jour on voudrait bien
reconnaître que les maires ont porté il
un groupe proposait aux assesseurs dire
que les assesseurs serait priorité pour
le vaccin pas prioritaires pour le
vaccin pourquoi pas les seuls à paris
laissons le gouvernement faire moi je
suis pas du tout pour la bourse aux
idées la fin c'est bien on peut tous en
avoir mais moi j'ai toujours eu cette
même doctrine de dire écoutez dans ces
moments là il faut une unité de
commandement laissons le gouvernement
prendre ses décisions et nous nous
immergeons maire vous êtes vous dit
c'est mieux pour les experts il n'y a
pas de doute je vous le dirai ce temps
il n'ya pas de doute il faut tout ce
sera mieux toutes les règles qui
permettront de nous aider à faire on les
prendra bien volontiers ce que vous
allez par exemple réfléchir à mettre des
bureaux de vote dehors puisque
conséquent espérons sera à ce moment là
tout ce qui sera possible de faire pour
préserver les uns et les autres
juste un mot sur l'évolution du mode
mais le plus important c'est que la
démocratie fonctionne vraiment sur
l'évolution du mode de scrutin puisque
c'est un des reproches entre guillemets
du conseil scientifique 1 qui disait que
le gouvernement n'avait pas réfléchi à
l'évolution notamment le vote par
correspondance le vote électronique est
ce que vous aussi
c'est quelque chose que vous dites on
n'a pas suffisamment réfléchi à comment
faire évoluer ce mode de scrutin mais on
le dit à chaque élection donc oui c'est
vrai qu'on doit pouvoir faire mieux en
termes de modernisation ayant ce débat
au calme mais pas simplement par rapport
à la crise sanitaire ayant le tout court
je pense qu'effectivement il ya un
certain nombre de pratiques de vote qui
sont un peu décalé par rapport à la
capacité du numérique de faciliter la
vie des électeurs travaillons aussi
tranquillement on va pas régler le
problème d'ici le mois de juin on va
parler de la crise sanitaire de la
vaccination notamment
oui le gouvernement étant la vaccination
aux plus de 55 ans avec astrazeneca et
vaccins johnson johnson près de 11000 11
millions de personnes ont reçu une dose
de vaccin on est au delà de
de l'objectif de 10 millions de
personnes vaccinées à la mi-mars à
mi-avril
est ce que vous pensez qu'on est
vraiment en train de passer d'accélérer
sur la vaccination est ce que vous êtes
rassurera je crois en la camorra nil
sont développées je crois qu il ya eu on
vous l'a tous dit
niveau des mers on l'a observé des ratés
énorme des retards énormes mais ces
dames et mais enfin moi je vois bien à
temps ce qui se passe c'est une
dynamique est enclenchée
nous avons de plus en plus de personnes
qui viennent contribuer à l'organisation
des choses et nous le voyons un mot nous
le voyons donc pas d'un simple d'autres
endroits mais je vois bien que très
concrètement nous avons maintenant
considérablement amélioré notre
organisation bon donc tout ça et bien il
faut continuer pour rien lâcher sur ces
sujets je suis là aussi de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut accompagner le
gouvernement on a tous des critiques on
a tous des amertumes sur tel ou tel
sujet mais peu importe il faut
absolument avancer car l'art
véritablement nous sommes tous dans le
même combat contre contre ce virus donc
ça y est maintenant on y va
ça avance correctement j'espère vraiment
pis y un oui mais suffisantes de vaccins
bah oui enfin ça y est maintenant ça
arrive je vais pas vous dire que c'est
parfait mais c'est de mieux en mieux
chaque semaine nous progressons et donc
il faut continuer dans cette dynamique
est donc vraiment éviter les polémiques
dénoncer les ratés quand il y en a bien
sûr mais on avance du même pas c'est
l'intérêt supérieur de notre pays qui
est en jeu ça veut dire que vous croyez
au cap qu'à fixer le président la
république nous réouverture début de
réouverture progressive est de retour à
la normale à partir du mois de mai la mi
mai comme disent nos amis anglais qui en
savent quelque chose fingers crossed
espérons voilà
la seule chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut être le si je puis dire le nez sur
le guidon on avance on fait le plus
possible et puis on guette tous les
jours les indicateurs en espérant qu'ils
baissent en parlant des indicateurs
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui à mon
cal et la situation sanitaire est ce que
les mesures restrictives font effet oui
j'espère vous savez nous sommes
malheureusement l'un des départements la
seine-et-marne parmi les plus impactés
notre notre région du nord
seine-et-marne l'a été également on a un
groupement hospitalier extraordinaire on
a fusionné il ya quelques années le
vital de meaux coulommiers et lasnier
donc avec ça on a maintenant un
groupement hospitalier très important
qui coordonne les soins et puis en
médecine de ville tout le monde est
mobilisé
on vaccine on fait du mieux qu'on peut
et encore une fois on n'est pas aux jeux
olympiques de celui qui fera le mieux
possible on essaye les uns et les autres
de serrer les coudes et je crois que
c'est la seule le seul mode horde
possible en cette période
a priori la france devrait
malheureusement franchir cette semaine à
barder les symbolique des 100 blizzard
est ce qu'on pensait que ces moments
d'organiser quelque chose en terme de
mémoire de commémoration ce que
président la république devrait prendre
la parole ou c'est trop tôt je pense que
c'est trop tôt d'abord parce que
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas être
certains que cette vague est
complètement enrayée il ya tout le sujet
des variants qui est un sujet
malheureusement très préoccupant pour
pour tout le monde
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est dans le
combat de toute façon il faut pas s'y
tromper
nous allons avoir après la crise
sanitaire une crise sociale une crise
économique qui va être très forte et à
laquelle il faut nous préparer car si je
n'avais qu'à regret c'est que je trouve
que la france n'a pas montré une grande
capacité d'anticipation sur les étapes
que nous avons eu à franchir on a
toujours été pris de court il faut
vraiment qu'on commence à réfléchir à la
manière d'accompagner les millions de
françaises et français qui vont se
trouver confronté à un traumatisme post
crise y compris psychique qui sera très
fort sur les notions de presse
sanitaires et passeports vaccinale
quelle est votre position à vous sur ces
questions là c'est attentoire liberté ou
non
ce sera je pense que ce sera un élément
de liberté puisque le monde entier
voilà donc le monde entier va avoir peur
et donc il faut il faut donner un
passeport pour voyager et où passe aussi
par exemple pour aller dans certains
retrouvés certains certaines pratiques
le culturel les restaurants ne le
considère pas comme une comme étant une
atteinte à la liberté il ya eu des
sujets qui peuvent lui faire penser mais
ça c'est plutôt un gage de liberté sur
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour nom il court jusqu'au 1er juin est
ce que vous dites qu on a atteint les
limites de l'acceptabilité ou est ce que
vous dites il va falloir le prolonger
compte tenu de la situation d'attendre
si on arrive si on arrive à tenir d'ici
cette date et à faire ralentir les
indicateurs ça voudra vraiment dire
qu'on a réussi la campagne de
vaccination donc là aussi j'ai envie de
vous dire
geron cela étape par étape juste un mot
sur ce que vous nous avez dit sur
l'étape d'après notamment concernant le
social et l'économie particulièrement
sur l'économie comment on en sort il
fait une sortie progressive du quoi
qu'il en coûte
il faut commencer à réfléchir aux
économies qu'on devra faire pour
rembourser la dette
il faut travailler secteur par secteur
il ya des secteurs qui sont durablement
sinistrés ils doivent continuer d'être
la priorité le tourisme l'hôtellerie le
transport aérien et l'industrie
automobile il ya des secteurs qui ont
été très très très impacté après pour
les autres on peut très vite commencé à
libérer si je puis dire enfin restreint
des aides là où on en a le moins besoin
mais mais faisons le vraiment au cas par
cas l'erreur
ce serait souhaite continuer comme si de
rien était soit de tout arrêter d'un
coup il faut réfléchir au remboursement
de la dette dès maintenant elle frôle
les 120 % du pib ou vous dit non c'est
trop tôt on verra ça après il ya une
chose qui est certaine c'est qu'il faut
rembourser la dette et il faut la
rembourser de manière assumée
je suis l'occasion et quelques jours
avec eric woerth de présenter des
propositions en matière de réforme de
l'état il est capital d' assumer le
remboursement de la dette qu'ensuite on
sait par la dette qu vide certes
directement lié aux dépenses que vides
de la dette classique oui bien sûr pour
que les gens comprennent à quoi ça
ressemble tout ça mais ne nous y
trompons pas il faut rembourser la dette
de telle manière
diminuer les dépenses publiques inutiles
veillez à avoir un échelonnement dans le
temps qu'ils soient
évidemment un peu plus long mais qu'ils
soient là aussi avec un début une fin et
que tout cela se fasse avec un nouveau
modèle départ parce qu'en vérité
tout cela montre quoi il faut un nouveau
modèle d'état dans lequel on assume plus
clairement deux grands piliers d'un côté
l'autorité qui est terriblement
défaillante
aujourd'hui la situation de sécurité de
notre pays est totalement fragilisé
depuis les cyberattaques jusqu'à la
délinquance et puis d'autre part le
progrès qu est le deuxième grand pilier
ou là il faut faire les il faut faire
confiance aux acteurs
nous avons vu à l'occasion de cette
crise de grands échecs dans le domaine
scientifique
nous n'avons pas suffisamment fait
confiance au secteur privé dans le
domaine du développement durable où il
ya des innovations formidable plutôt de
contraint d'être sanctionné développons
ce qui doit l'être dans le domaine bien
sûr du progrès économique où là aussi il
faut laisser faire les acteurs il y a je
le vois bien à travers mes fonctions de
maire mais aussi d'avocats à la
rencontre d'un certain nombre
d'entrepreneurs en difficulté des gens
qui veulent se battre et donc il faut
absolument les accompagner dans ce
combat c'est ça le rôle de l'état et
c'est pour cela qu'il faut repenser le
modèle d'état plutôt que d'intervenir
partout l'actualité parlementaire le
sénat a voté hier la loi séparatisme et
en durcissant le texte notamment sur la
question du voile est ce que les
sénateurs eu raison de le faire
écoutez ça dépend ce qu'on entend par
durcissement sur le voile je pense qu'il
ya des combats qu'il faut absolument
mener
vous le savez j'ai porté la loi
d'interdiction de la burqa en france
avec un réel succès la burqa c'est le
masque intégral qui était un véritable
déni d'identité et qui a permis à chacun
de prendre conscience qu'on ne pouvait
pas faire n'importe quoi y compris pour
des raisons religieuses au sein de la
république
la question du port du voile on ne peut
pas la plagne la positionner dans toutes
les circonstances que ce soit dans le
cadre du service public
oui bien sûr et notamment de l'école que
ce soit à l'intérieur de lieux publics
tout ça se comprend parfaitement que
l'on reste ferme pour les fonctionnaires
même chose et j'ai sur l'école sénat eu
raison de voter l'interdiction du voile
pour les accompagnatrices oui
vieux sujet qu'il fallait trancher en
revanche l'interdît à prétendre vouloir
l'interdire dans l'espace public est un
combat qui de mon point de vue n'a pas
sa raison d'être aujourd'hui au regard
de ce qu'est devenue la société
française et je le vois là aussi en tant
que maire d'une ville dont la communauté
musulmane est la deuxième communauté
religieuse de la vie alors là il y avait
interdiction pour les mineurs
interdiction du voile pour les mineurs
ça c'est vous êtes favorable moi je
pense que je pense que ce sera compliqué
de deux lits parvenir mais après tout
c'est un débat qu'il fallait avoir est
de ce point de vue on verra ce qu'il en
sera pour moi le combat à mener
il est sur toutes les cases manquantes
du texte et en cela le calvez le le ceta
pardon a fait un remarquable travail il
faut saluer et j'espère que le
gouvernement va l'entendre il ya
beaucoup de sujets sur lesquels il faut
aller plus loin
la question de l'école la question
d'aider des conditions de construction
des lieux de cultes me paraît être un
sujet absolument majeur ce qui se passe
à strasbourg en dit long sur les dégâts
commis par un certains nombre de maires
qui se prétendent écologistes mais ça ça
n'est pas de l'écologie en réalité c'est
l'illustration de ce qui est devenu la
gauche française c'est à dire qu'elle a
renoncé à la laïcité et de ce point de
vue d'ailleurs lc2 terriblement
fragilisé le pays de l'alloeu
heureusement mais malheureusement une
bonne partie d'entre elles parce que le
ps est fracturée en deux sur ce sujet et
une partie du ps est parti vers les
verts et l'extrême gauche un mélenchon
et c est dans une logique qui au nom de
la défense de minorités se retrouve avec
les islamistes les plus radicaux
et c'est ça qui est dangereux et c'est
ça qu'il faut combattre et donc le rôle
des républicains qu'il soit 2,2 de
centre-droit ou de centre gauche c'est
de se mobiliser contre cela parce que
sinon vous avez un blog d'extrême gauche
très puissant qui y vivent qui a versé
vers l'islamo gauchisme de l'autre
l'extrême droite qui est en embuscade et
le risque pour la république est
considérable et donc il faut être très
ferme et l'exemple de strasbourg comme
ce qui s'est passé avec l'amendement
pour
verville montre que en pratique il faut
absolument être vigilant et ferme sur
les financements non tracée par des pays
étrangers de lieux de culte alors là en
l'occurrence c'est le gouvernement qui a
déposé cette absolue donc ça veut dire
que là vous êtes d'accord avec gérald
darmanin il a bien fait de réagir il a
fermement si rapide il a tout à fait
bien fait il faut être ferme là dessus
et il faut aller dans ce domaine très
loin de la même manière il y avait
d'autres cases manquantes dans la loi je
pense à la question des prisons je pense
à la question des salles de sport sur
tous ces sujets il faut être beaucoup
plus faire est ce que le maire que vous
êtes avec cette loi va lutter plus
facilement contre le séparatisme dans sa
commune est ce que ça vous donne plus
d'outils quand même bah oui bien sûr
bien sûr ne serait ce que parce que il
faut renforcer et c'est ça qui sous
jacent à cette loi la coopération entre
le monde les maires et les services de
l'état
parce que pendant trop longtemps les
consignes les maires ont été considérés
comme quantité négligeable lors qu'ils
sont au coeur du sujet et les premiers à
voir les problèmes
donc nous fait moi je vois bien je
dialogue depuis des années des années
avec les responsables de toutes les
communautés religieuses et donc y
compris la communauté musulmane hameau
dans un contexte qui d'ailleurs est tout
à fait bon et qui permet d'anticiper les
choses un mot sur l'ena stéphane sur
l'ena oui vous avez vous avez qualifié
de pathétique la décision d' emmanuel
macron de supprimer l'ena telle qu'elle
est aujourd'hui en disant qu'il allait
dans le sens des populistes oui ce que
vous pourriez précisé sagesse qu'on
avait plaisir east de voir les affaires
mais vraiment vous êtes vous êtes triste
de voir les nains fermé ben pas vous non
pas parce que sans doute parce que
votre conviction personnelle peut-être
votre engagement mais pas le sentiment
sur ce surnom dans ce domaine là d'abord
un je vois pas le drame
ben c'est pas grave ne pas être sans
arrêt dans la bien pensante et puis
deuxièmement je voudrais vous dire ce
que je pense profondément vous écoute je
pense que notre pays se meurt d'être en
permanence en train de chercher des
boucs émissaires pour s'exonérer de ses
propres responsabilités s'il suffisait
de supprimer l'ena pour régler les
problèmes de la france ça se saurait
c'est en réalité un ton cv la libye
c'est une fausse réponse vient problème
c'est un très bel alibi la libye pour
éviter de se poser la seule question qui
vaille qui est qui et comment on
modernise l'état comment est-ce qu'on
gère les carrières des hauts
fonctionnaires
qu'est ce qu'ils font en réduit la
fracture entre les ponts appelle
aujourd'hui la liste
c'est sûr que si vous supprimez l'élite
vous serez plus embêté là il y aura en
place un concert sur internet pour
pleurer on casse le thermomètre sa
pullman à 10 mais c'est même plus une
question de tel quel c'est le
thermomètre c'est pire que ça la france
est riche de tous ses talents
elle est riche de sa diversité et quand
on veut se débarrasser de ceux qui
s'engagent qui travaillent qui
réussissent à un moment ou un autre on
le paye vous savez c'est pas l'école
nationale d'administration qui est en
cause ce n'est certainement pas ces
élèves c'est la manière dont on gère les
carrières et plus globalement c'est la
défaillance du politique
car le véritable sujet il n'a jamais été
demandée aux énarques j'en sais quelque
chose de commander le pays
il leur a été demandé d'appliquer la
politique pour laquelle ils sont nommés
dans leur fonction là quelle politique
est déterminé par les responsables
politiques élus au suffrage universel
quand est ce que les énarques en font à
leur guise quand les politiques ne
décide pas parce que quand un politique
décide ça change tout vous savez je
voudrais juste un exemple il ya lorsque
j'étais élève à l'ena j'avais confié un
et professeurs que je voulais faire de
la politique et m'engager pour le pays
au niveau politique qui m'avait dit copé
je vais vous dire un truc si un jour
vous voulez être un grand ministre si
vous voulez véritablement contribué à
faire ce lien entre la politique
l'administration et le pays
n'oubliez jamais que le mini
c'est pas celui qui fait une bonne
émission à la télé c'est pas celui qui
donne son nom de famille à une loi c'est
celui qui commande son administration
quant à ministre commente pas son
administration avec un reporter in
précis par ses directeurs qui sont
souvent des gens très brillants mais qui
attendent des consignes pour les
appliquer c'est là que ça des
défaillances son administration
donc le vrai sujet il est là il est pas
ailleurs et derrière ce message de
fausse suppression de l'ena il ya de la
part d' emmanuel macron l'idée de dire
c'est pas nous c'est les autres
et ça pour moi c'est insupportable on va
parler des républicains pour terminer
vous avez sans doute dû ce sondage dans
le journal du dimanche sondage ifop
personne chez les républicains est en
mesure d'éviter un duel macron le pen au
second tour pour le moment on est loin
de l'élection ce n'est qu'un sondage
mais ce que quand même ce n'est pas
révélateur d'un échec de la droite la
droite ne s'est jamais remise de
l'élection d' emmanuel macron du fait de
l'éparpillement des talents qui ont
quitté l air et l'air n'est plus ce
qu'était l'ump lorsque j'ai quitté mes
fonctions en 2014 nous avions un parti
politique qui représentait trois à
quatre cent mille militants et
sympathisants très engagé aujourd'hui
nous sommes 60 milles c'était en 2014
un parti qui avait gagné brillamment les
municipales et ensuite les européennes
c'est aujourd'hui un parti qui aux
dernières élections européennes a fait
8% des voix
nous ne pouvons plus hélas mais qui à
présent la gagner les municipales quand
même qui a préservé qui à préserver
l'acquis des municipales tout à fait
remarquablement mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement l air n'est plus grands
partis qui étaient l'ump et qui pouvait
légitimement par une primaire être
suffisamment large dans son socle
électoral pour incarner un candidat donc
la primaire ça peut plus marcher
il faut l'assumer une bonne fois pour
toutes sauf à vouloir faire une campagne
de notoriété pour tel ou tel candidat
c'est pas notre but notre but il est
d'essayer de voir comment proposer une
alternative parmi les partis de
gouvernement donc il faut réfléchir un
peu plus largement et c'est pour ça que
je ne suis pas favorable de la primaire
et que je pense qu'il faudra regarder la
réalité des choses à travers des
indications comme les sondages pour voir
celui ou celle qui le mieux
ou la mieux placée largement ça va
jusqu'où jean françois copé est ce que
vous dites la droite ne sera peut-être
pas en mesure d'avoir un candidat ce
qu'il faudra qu'on soutienne ce macron
si on est incapable d'avoir un candidat
il va bien falloir qu'on rencontre ont
choisi ce nom on en est très loin pour
l'instant moi sur mon inquiétude pour
vous dire les choses telles que je les
ressens aujourd'hui mon inquiétude c'est
que quoi quoi que disent les
commentateurs les journalistes les
sondeurs il y a comme jamais le risque
de voir marine le pen élue la présence
de la république
faire semblant d'iran mais elle connaît
pas ses chiffres elle fait peur elle
connaît pas ses dossiers
tout ça c'est une folie aujourd'hui la
réalité des choses c'est que marine le
pen elle travaille activement son image
elle explique qu'elle aime tout le monde
elle rassure tous ceux qui le souhaitent
et quand en plus le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur darmanin lui dit en
plein débat en v non mais vous êtes
devenu très molle ben ça veut dire quoi
derrière c'est une autorisation à voter
pour elle bon donc je vous dis moi que
l' alerte elle est majeure il faut donc
que la droite républicaine et le centre
droit propose une alternative si nous ne
le faisons pas nous aurons les pires
risque parce que je crains qu emmanuel
macron ne puisse pas être réélu face à
marine le pen du contexte psychologique
parce que les albigeois encore le temps
de faire ce travail-là se trouver le bon
candidat sera bien sûr pas être une
primaire et notre parti peut tout à fait
décider de soutenir une personnalité
après tout ça a toujours été l'histoire
à droite n'y a jamais eu de vote leur
père n'a jamais choisi son candidat par
un vote
il a soutenu un candidat que ce soit par
exemple à l'époque les repères que ce
soit jacques chirac l'ump a fait
exactement la même chose avec nicolas
sarkozy on n'a pas voté
la primaire de la dernière cène et quand
même un candidat fort dans votre camp
est ce que là vous dites mais on
pourrait soutenir
emmanuel macron pourrait soutenir
edouard philippe par exemple au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup trop tôt
pour vous le dire je pense qu'il faut
proposer une alternative au match
emmanuel macron marine le pen
et sinon le pire est à craindre c'est
notre responsabilité de le faire ils en
mesure de l'incarner aujourd'hui il est
en pole position mais valérie pécresse
elle aussi
des ambitions il y à des inconnus dans
l'équation vous avez cité douar philippe
tout à l'heure moi je note simplement
une chose pour ce qui me concerne je
plaiderai pour que l'on soutienne celui
qui est le mieux placé pour être
qualifié au deuxième tour car
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas qualifiés
au deuxième tour et moi j'invite ceux
qui ont fait des petits scores dans le
dernier sondage à se regarder dans la
glace et à se demander si c'est vraiment
l'horreur un dernier mot rapidement
françois baroin il est encore dans
l'équation vous les chiraquiens
je crois que non j'ai compris que non
puisque lui-même il a fait comprendre
merci beaucoup merci jean françois copé
d'avoir évité ce matin regarder une
réponse des fans enlèvement on haïti le
chaos politique dans un pays gangrené
merci ses fans d'avoir été avec no mercy
mission
[Musique]